Bonjour, nous sommes en septembre, les feuilles
tombent, et pour certains d'entre vous, que
vous soyez profs ou élèves...
C'est la rentrée.
-Quelle motivation.
-C'est pour coller à ce thème que j'ai décidé
de faire une vidéo sur l'histoire de l'histoire,
eh ouais, ou plutôt l'histoire de l'enseignement
de l'histoire.
Si vous êtes allés un jour à l'école primaire,
vous vous souvenez peut-être des grandes
dates et personnages qu'on vous a martelé.
-Charlemagne!
-800!
-Clovis?
-Le vase de Soissons!
-1515?
-Marignan!
-En 50 avant Jésus-Christ?
-Toute la Gaule est occupée, sauf...
Euh, pardon.
Pourquoi ces dates, pourquoi ces personnages,
qui nous a imposé cette vision de l'histoire
alors qu'on aurait pu apprendre à analyser
des trous de poteaux? C'est l'enquête que
nous allons mener dans cet épisode.
Sous l'Ancien Régime, c'est à dire avant
la Révolution Française, on enseigne surtout
l'histoire sainte à partir de l'Ancien et
du nouveau testament.
Et à la fin du XVIIIe siècle, juste avant
que la révolution ne bouscule tout, on commence
par l'histoire sainte dans les premières
classes, qui explique donc l'origine de l'humanité
pour l'époque.
-Oui et là tu vas dire un truc comme «hééé,
on a bien évolué depuis!»
-Pas du tout, tu trouveras encore quelques
écoles américaines où on enseigne le créationnisme
au lieu de l'évolution...
L'histoire au XVIIIe siècle continue avec
l'enseignement de l'Antiquité, pour finir
par l'histoire de France.
Un changement radical se produit à partir
des années 1870, avec la défaite des français
contre la Prusse, puisqu'on considère alors
que les français se sont fait écraser parce
qu'ils étaient moins patriotes que les allemands.
On cherche aussi à ancrer la IIIe République
qui vient tout juste de succéder au Second
Empire.
-A propos! Savez-vous pourquoi on dit Second
Empire et pas deuxième Empire, ou Seconde
guerre mondiale et pas deuxième guerre mondiale?
C'est parce qu'il n'y en a pas eu de troisième!
S'il y avait eu un troisième empire, on parlerait
de deuxième empire, tout comme on dit «deuxième
république». Merci.
-Pas mal...
Me pique pas mon boulot quand même.
Bref, le meilleur moyen de transmettre l'amour
de la nation aux plus jeunes, c'est bien sûr
en leur montrant à quel point leur pays a
une histoire grandiose.
On oublie l'histoire de la création du monde,
supprimée à partir de 1865, on laisse un
peu de côté l'Antiquité et on se concentre
sur l'Histoire de France en retenant des personnages
emblématiques qui illustreront la grandeur
de la nation.
-Comme moi?
-NON.
Comme nos ancêtres les gaulois, un peuple
guerrier et fort, représenté de manière
très caricaturale dans les manuels de la
IIIe République.
Tous les gaulois portent forcément un casque,
des braies et une moustache, et passent leur
temps à se taper dessus.
A les lire on croirait descendre des dothrakis.
D'autant que nous descendons tout aussi bien
des francs, des romains, et de tout un mélange
de peuples.
On préfère également se concentrer sur
la vie de certains personnages, plutôt que
sur une histoire plus globale de la manière
dont vivaient les populations.
L'étude de Clovis, notamment son baptême,
permet de montrer l'unité chrétienne de
la nation!
De même on apprend aux élèves la victoire
de Charles Martel contre les arabes à Poitiers
en 732, afin de mettre en valeur la capacité
du pays à repousser l'envahisseur.
Poitiers n'est pas la seule bataille entre
les arabes et les français durant cette période,
et il ne s'agissait pas de stopper une invasion
mais plutôt une petite incursion.
A tel point que les chroniques arabes mentionnent
très peu cet événement.
« 13 juillet 732.
Abd al Rahman n'est pas rentré de la cueillette
aux champignons.
Je pense qu'il est mort.
»
-Peut-être qu'ils avaient honte d'avoir perdu.
-Peut-être, mais de notre côté ça va faire
1300 ans qu'on se vante d'avoir gagné.
-Ne vous mettez donc pas trop Martel en tête.
-Les professeurs d'histoire abordent d'autres
personnages emblématiques comme Saint-Louis,
Louis XIV, et évidemment Jeanne d'Arc.
Jeanne d'Arc est une femme qui entendait la
voix de Dieu, qui a sauvé le roi de France,
a permis de renvoyer les anglais chez eux
et s'est sacrifiée pour son pays.
-C'est du pain béni!
-Quoi qu'un peu trop cuit.
Je ne vais pas revenir sur son parcours, mais
elle représente toutes les idées que l'Etat
sous la IIIe République veut transmettre
aux jeunes générations et c'est pourquoi
elle a été autant étudiée.
En un mot, comme en cent, l'histoire enseignée
aux élèves est au service de la nation,
et chaque partie du programme sert à transmettre
des valeurs, en plus des connaissances.
Ernest Lavisse, qui écrit le manuel scolaire
le plus utilisé entre 1884 et 1950, parle
d'une «histoire qui s'apprend par le coeur».
Et c'est beau.
De même, la géographie permet de montrer
la beauté du pays que nous habitons, et l'instruction
morale et civique permet d'en rajouter une
petite couche au cas où les enfants n'auraient
pas bien compris.
Les français sont forts.
La France est un beau pays.
Vous êtes français.
Ce n'est qu'après la seconde guerre mondiale
que les choses évoluent: l'histoire-géographie-éducation
civique prend une nouvelle tournure et a pour
vocation de lutter contre le racisme, l'intolérance,
afin de ne pas reproduire les horreurs qui
ont été commises pendant la guerre.
On veut donc enseigner une histoire universelle,
on ouvre les programmes à d'autres civilisations
d'Europe et même des autres continents, et
c'est ce vers quoi on tend aujourd'hui.
Retenez donc que l'écriture et l'enseignement
de l'histoire varient selon les périodes,
selon les courants de pensée...
Je vous ai parlé de l'histoire à l'école,
mais il en va de même au niveau universitaire.
Il y a eu de nombreuses manières d'écrire
l'histoire, et la plupart des historiens essayent
de rester le plus objectif possible mais il
est difficile de rester totalement objectif
à partir du moment où on travaille sur une
source, qui peut être incomplète, mal interprétée,
etc.
J'espère que cette nouvelle vidéo vous a
intéressé, si vous êtes collégiens ou
lycéens je suis sûre que vous avez maintenant
hâte d'ouvrir vos manuels d'histoire pour
voir de quoi parle le programme.
Et si vous en avez fini avec tout ça, vous
pouvez vous replonger dans vos vieux cahiers
si vous ne vous en êtes pas servis pour recréer
la mort de Jeanne d'Arc.
-T'as quoi d'écrit sur mon époque?
-SPOILER!
Merci d'avoir regardé, bonne rentrée pour
certains et à bientôt!